Hot off the wire today.
(audience applauds)
And it's funny
(Mayim laughs)
'cause in the commercial break, I'm like,
"Wait, I'm obsessed with your shoes.
Where did you get them?"
(Mayim and audience laughing)
I got them on DSW.
Yes.
So I don't wear leather.
And it's often hard to find shoes.
A lot of things have leather.
And so many companies, though,
are now making things that are pleather.
And to me, I don't need to wear leather
to wear a fun green heel, and there it is.
(audience applauds)
I love that.
(Mayim chuckles)
And it has nothing to do with the fact
that this story has hit the wire.
But okay, so apparently, all day, people are freaking out
on Twitter and Instagram and social media
and every portal about your jacket.
But did you know that your hair and outfit were making like-
I did not.
I mean-
It's everywhere.
My mother, actually, mentioned this to me
before it was anywhere else.
Maybe she started it.
She said, "I noticed you didn't wear a blazer.
You wore a sweater."
And I said, "What is she talking about?"
I said, "I always wear a blazer."
And then I thought it was the sweater blazer.
There it is.
(audience laughs)
That's a sweater?
Well, it's like sweatery material, yeah.
Oh, it's very lovely.
It's a very beautiful color, too.
It's a shocking color,
but it was autumn.
(audience laughs)
So I was gonna say,
(Mayim laughs)
a lot of people are saying,
"Oh, she's already worn that jacket
and she's wearing it again."
With no attitude, no negativity.
There's nothing slanderous
or upsetting about it.
(Mayim laughs)
Just an absolute observant obsessive commenting
about how you repeated a jacket.
(audience laughs)
I mean, look, for men in these hosting positions,
they also change clothes every episode,
but they wear a blue suit, a gray suit, a black suit,
and they just like change the ties.
It's less noticeable.
But also, I like when people repeat something
because that's what normal life is.
Yeah.
You know what's not normal life
(Mayim laughs)
(audience applauds)
is like
being able to change your outfit.
I mean, this top, I've worn several times on the show.
These pants, they're dusty at this point.
(Mayim and audience laughing)
I wear them so often.
That's what we do.
We mix and match and pair, so-
I've never worn this. This is just for you.
(Mayim and audience laughing)
(audience applauds)
And I will never wear that blazer again. That's it.
(audience laughs)
It's done.
Well, apparently, if you do, they're going to notice.
(Mayim and audience laughing)
Now, with all the reboots going on,
have you ever considered a "Blossom" reboot?
(audience applauds)
(audience cheers)
So we have not had a conversation about a full reboot.
Don Reo, who created "Blossom"
and was our executive producer for years,
he and I actually...
Well, he has a dramatic script with the characters
from "Blossom" that he and I have been working on for years.
It would be a very different way to think of a reboot.
But on "Call Me Kat," our first episode of the season,
we had Joey Lawrence, and Jenna von Oy,
and Michael Stoyanov on.
And I'll go ahead
(audience applauds)
and I'll give you a little fun reveal.
You're the first one
(Drew squeals)
I'm telling.
In our finale, Ted Wass, was who played my dad
on "Blossom," is playing Kat's father in a fantasy sequence.
(audience applauds)
So it's like a full-circle "Blossom," yeah.
Oh, my God.
We're very excited.
Are you pulling
a Bob Newhart?
I mean, we're very excited.
Also, for us, it's just like a sweet little bookend
to season two that we started with the cast of "Blossom,"
and we're ending.
And Ted Wass, also, is a very accomplished director.
And so for him to like come out of acting kind of retirement
and come to play Kat's dad, we're very, very excited.
So I would need things to quiet down a little in my life
so that I'm not also holding two jobs.
I also have a podcast called "Mayim Bialik's Breakdown,"
all about mental health.
Which is the one
that gave me-
(audience applauds)
So I'm very busy. I'm very busy.
Listen to the podcast, too.
It is full of life revelations, one-
It's really fun.
Of which I've been
the beneficiary because I'm a listener.
And everything that you do, we are here for it.
Thank you. That's very sweet.
Mayim Bialik.
(audience applauds)
Thank you.
"As They Made Us,"
her gorgeous writer-director film that's very personal
is in theaters an On Demand now with a stellar cast
and a beautiful approach to storytelling.
It really is.
And you are just...
I love you so bad.
Thank you. (laughs)
(upbeat pop music)